and the Oscar goes to Ben Affleck
I don't think any of us are going to
sleep tonight I just said to Matt losing
would suck and winning would be really
scary and it's really really scary world
of understatements pretty cool would be
the king yeah no this is about as
unbelievable as anything that's ever
happened to us how do you like their
Maps we never thought that anyone would
buy it or that it would actually go
through the Hollywood sort of channels
much less you know
and they're putting Academy Awards for
God's sake
Robin Williams
because the odds are one to one so it
was like Hey one way or the other but
then all of a sudden when they announced
the name this might be the one time I'm
speechless
oh
thank you so much for this incredible
honor and then it came back to me and
then I went oh if there's people okay a
billion okay now move for a moment lips
don't fail me now it was rough thank you
Ben and Matt I still want to see some ID
but you're a genius right you move Chief
when a big time movie star like that
goes out on a limb and puts their name
on a movie like Goodwill Hunting which
you know was not certainly not a
guaranteed success he just did it
because he he you know he liked it and
if any and he really could relate to the
role and and you know he cut his price
and he you know he did he made a lot of
sacrifices in order to be a part of it
and
um and I'm I'm glad that's rewarded you
don't know what to do so
you owe it to me I know he's going to
bring his mom I'm going to bring mine so
they're probably coordinating more than
more than we are it's very exciting I
had a pretty normal day although it
started early because I had to run and
get a bow tie I left it at my friend's
house I was like you know so it was a
bit you know air Indy the only thing I
just had to do today was uh look for my
cumberbund which my friends go and I
still don't have come on it's me it's me
Will remember we went to kindergarten
together the secret to working together
is abuse each other and so if you can't
be honest with the guy you work with who
can you be honest with I think we really
don't pull any punches when we critique
learn how to take a hit you know we shut
this whole operation down right now and
we never would have thought really that
it was possible I mean even 15 years ago
people you didn't think of independent
movies as something that was you know
you you could do so Matt and I thought
that we could really make the movie by
just raising a little bit of money the
problem with being an actor is that and
which means most of the time you're not
going to be working and you're going to
be trying to be working and it's really
really difficult to feel like you you
own your own life
it's not your fault
I know
it's not their fault I think I'll see
the picture and I'll go wow you know I
guess I really was there but I was like
I just won an Academy Award and you're
watching Entertainment Tonight
[Music]